- Thank you to Shillshare
for being the sponsor of this video.
One of the topics that I'm
really passionate about
is slide writing.
And slide writing is
the science, or the art,
of creating slide presentations
in the style of leading
consulting firms like MBB
and this is McKinsey, BCG, and Bain.
As you probably already know
if you're a regular
watcher of this channel,
I worked at McKinsey for six years.
I taught slide writing inside the firms
to junior colleagues, but
I'm also giving trainings
on slide writing to corporations
and I also serve as a
lecturer on communication
and slide writing.
For instance, at the University
of St. Gallen MBA program.
So today, I will help you
to build your slide
writing skills as well,
and I will do this by
reviewing slide presentations
that you sent me.
So I asked you on Instagram to
send me some of the documents
that you are working on,
for instance from university projects,
and I received several
submissions from you.
So we're going to look
into this in a moment.
But before we do that,
I just wanna be really clear on one thing.
So maybe some of you are
asking yourselves now
where did all my hair go?
And due to the special
situation in Germany,
all the hair dresses are
closed at the moment.
So, no, I did not bribe any
professional to cut my hair.
I just asked my sister to do it.
And if you're following me on Instagram,
you know exactly what happens
and you also know why this
maybe was not the best idea.
But let's not talk more
about this right now.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
It's already pretty late here in Germany
so I'm drinking tea.
Please help yourself to a cup as well.
But now without further
ado, let's jump in.
So I'm looking now at
the screen in front of me
where I open several of the
presentations that you sent me.
So of course we won't go
over every presentation
slide by slide, but I always
selected a couple of slides
that I believe will be most
educational to discuss.
So just bear in here with me and trust
there are some very, very important
and valuable slide writing lessons
that we'll now jointly identify and find
while looking at these pages.
And here, let's start with this one,
there seems to be some type
of university presentation
about an economics class,
the Turkish growth miracle.
So frankly, I have no
idea about the topic.
So let's just look at this page.
What do we see here?
So my first impression is that
this page looks kind of messy
but of course the question
is, why does it look messy?
What makes this page look messy?
And if you look into this,
probably the main reason
is that this page uses all
kinds of different font sizes.
And this is really a problem
that you see quite often.
So let's look.
Here of course, the action title 28.
Here this title, 24.
Red curve, depreciation 18,
this one 20,
this one 18,
18 here in the chart 12,
but here also in the chart 18.
It's really all over the place.
And I believe this
really significantly adds
to this unclean, to this
weird unorganized look.
So the key rule that
you always wanna follow
when doing these types of presentations
that the body of your slide,
so everything except for the title
and maybe some footnotes,
should be the same font size.
So now let's look at the chart.
Let's look at how this chart is created.
And the first thing that pops into my eye
are these very thick, dotted lines.
So usually if you make dotted lines,
you don't want them to be so dominant.
You want them to be light
and in the background,
but here because these are
one of the thickest lines
in this shot, they're
very dominant, right?
And this just doesn't look right.
And next, this here, the different colors.
So this is a green line,
a red line, a blue line.
The general rule is that
whenever you use colors
on your page, it either
has a direct meaning
or the needs to be legend.
And again, this will look cleaner,
nicer, more sophisticated.
My last comment is just switching here
between these two slides.
So what you see here is
that several elements
are jittering, are moving.
This is also something you wanna avoid.
So let's look at the action type.
You see, this is moving.
This means that this isn't
nicely and properly aligned.
And of course, this will be noticed
if you save this as a PDF or whatever
and you just scroll through it
and you see all these elements
moving from page to page,
this just looks not
aligned, not professional.
The same, of course
here also with the text
with these bullets and same
thing here with the footer.
Why is this moving again?
Make sure that you have
no jarring on your pages.
This just looks unprofessional.
Next presentation.
So this is apparently a
deck about Rockefeller.
So some information, some facts on him.
And here my first impression
is that this does already
look a bit more organized,
a bit more clean than the
slides that we saw before.
And if you look at this,
you can see some good
slide writing principles followed here.
And if you're more interested in that
because I cannot now go into
every little piece of that,
I actually created a whole
course on slide writing,
on how to create PowerPoint presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms.
So if you're interested with
that and wanna learn more,
check out the link in
the video description.
I have over 10,000
students taking the course.
I trust that might be
interesting for some of you.
Now, I wanna focus on this specific page
and again, it looks not too bad.
So it has a proper action title
or the text here is of the same text size.
So one thing that you
could do to further improve
is add separator lines.
So for some reason, this still
looks a bit unfinished to me.
It seems like something is
missing here on this page.
And I believe one thing
is these separator lines
that you could include
between these elements
to make it look a bit more organized.
Then the next question is
also, so what exactly is this?
So these elements are introduced here.
What elements are these exactly?
What am I looking at right now?
What is the title, or
the organizing principle,
of these elements?
So if I understand this correctly
also from inferring it
from the action title,
this is probably something
like the competitive advantages
that Rockefeller had
or the things that he did,
the measures that he undertook
to increase its market share.
And if this is what it is,
then also add this as
a little subtitle here
just to make it more clean.
The next one, let's look at the chart.
And again, here basic slide
writing principles are followed.
The one thing that I wanna
give you as general tip,
and this is that whenever
you use percentages,
always add the percentage
of what are you looking at.
The percentage of what.
One question that you could
potentially ask yourself
when you look at the market share
is that whether this is the
market share measured in units
or the market share measured in US dollar.
So this here just remains unclear
and this could be easily fixed
just by making your self
a habit of always writing
percentage of what,
solve the market units
or the market in dollars.
So let's move to the next presentation.
This looks like some type of
business pitch of a product
which seems to be a chair that
is included in a backpack.
So interesting idea for sure.
Again, let's just pick
one slide to this one.
Let's just focus on this.
And this apparently is
the page in this document
where the market and
industry for this product
is supposed to be explained.
So here, the first thing that you see
is that it's really hard to understand
what the message of all of
this really is supposed to be.
What is now really the thing
that I should take away
from this page?
And here the clearest
thing that is missing
is the action title.
So here you see the title
is just market and industry.
This is pretty much just the header,
but a clear action title is missing
and this is exactly why
it's just super difficult
to really understand what the message is.
If you have no idea
what I'm talking about,
if you don't know what an action title is,
then check out my video
that I made specifically
on action titles.
It's where I explain what it's all about,
action title's our fundamental piece
of every slide presentation.
Check out the video here
to learn more about it
where I discussed this in the past.
And now if you look into this,
you'll see again
different font sizes used.
This is font 20.
This is font 18.
Of course this here is something
that you can barely read.
The general rule is,
especially for professional presentations,
never just copy paste charts like that.
But especially if you
already have the numbers,
if they already apparently present here,
just recreate the chart in PowerPoint.
It will always look much
better and much cleaner.
But here so much remains in the dark.
So pains of the industry.
What industry exactly are
you talking about here?
So is this the sports and outdoor market?
Is this the industry?
As far as I can see, this was
also not properly introduced
on the pages before.
So really hard to understand.
Same thing here for this chart.
So what exactly is this
chart supposed to tell me?
So understand that here below
there's some type of market
sizing for the Portuguese market
but here this chart says
user penetration worldwide.
So the user penetration of what?
And here as far as I understand,
Portugal seems to have a rather low
to medium user penetration.
So what does this mean?
Is this good? Is this bad?
So again, I really have no idea
what this page is supposed to tell me,
what I'm supposed to
take out of this page.
So our next presentation,
this is a set of slides
that apparently talk about networking.
And overall, I must say,
they look professional,
they look very well done.
One thing though, I just
wanna put your attention
is that on a page like that,
there is just lots of text
and in almost all situations,
people will never read this much text.
Even if they get this handed as a report
or handed as a business presentation,
this is just something
that will not be read.
And what you could easily do here
is just to deword the whole page.
So take out lots of words
by keeping the full meaning
of what you see here
because indeed your
full sentences are used
as if you would read a book,
go on these slide presentations
so you usually wanna
say as much as possible
with as little words as possible
just to declutter it, to deword it.
And the main way to do this is of course
rather use bullet points style
instead of full sentences.
So just one little example,
instead of writing,
"The value of this information
depends on the trust
within the network,"
just write a bullet saying,
"Information value
depends on network trust."
So one little thing that you can often do
to take out words is to
delete articles like "the"
to deword the page.
And indeed another way to
improve your communication
and business skills is to take classes
on a platform like Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people.
You can explore new skills,
deepen your passions
and get lost in creativity.
There are classes on
marketing, personal branding,
presentation skills, and many more.
All of these are topics
that are highly applicable
to a career in consulting,
banking or corporate.
And the best thing is that I
made a slight writing class
for Skillshare so you
can access and enjoy it
as a Skillshare member.
Personally, I recently took the class
Productivity Masterclass-
Principles and Tools
to Boost Your Productivity
from the fellow YouTuber, Ali Abdaal.
It's a great class.
It taught me many new
aspects of productivity
and I very much enjoyed how
you apply the Pareto principle,
or the 80/20 rule to productivity.
Classes on Skillshare are
specifically curated for learning.
There are no ads.
They're always launching
new premium classes
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your
creativity takes you.
And the best thing is that
it's less than $10 a month
with an with endless subscription.
Skillshare created a special
offer for subscribers
of this channel, Firm Learning.
And so the first 1,000 subscribers of me
that click on the Skillshare
link in the video description
will get a free trial of the
Skillshare premium membership.
I hope this helps you to
explore your creativity.
Check it out, link in
the video description.
So now to the next presentation.
Here the one thing that I wanna point out
is how too much graphical things,
how too many animations
can really take away
from the content of the slides
and can even also look
unprofessional to some extent.
So here, if you go over,
there are so many animations,
so many colors that do not really add much
to the actual content,
to the actual meaning
that the things that you actually
wanna say with your slides
get completely diminished.
So here, just be sure that
you use graphical elements
like this and bold colors like
this very, very selectively.
Usually less is more and the
same is true for animations.
Usually there are no animations
in presentations like this.
One of the reasons being that
often these presentations
are not even getting presented,
but they're just printed out as documents
and then you just go over
these documents in a meeting
and everybody just has a handout
of this presentation document
in front of him or her.
But even if you are
presenting it on a display,
animations is just not the look and feel
that you should go for
for C level presentations.
It will be perceived as unprofessional.
This is just not what is expected from you
in these environments.
So now next one, and again,
this seems to be from
a university project.
And the reason why I included it
is just because I wanted to show you
the different type of style
that this presentation is using.
This is a presentation style
that you will see more
frequently in banking.
So in most consulting contexts,
pages like that would never
go into the main deck.
It's just far too much text.
Things like this would go in the back up.
But for whatever reason,
bankers just like to put even more words
in their presentations than consultants.
But this is indeed what you
will find if you join a bank.
I just wanna also make you
aware of one other specialty
that you often find in
these banking presentations
and this is the so-called
football field chart.
And this is exactly what you see here.
Bankers use this all the
time to display spreads
and company valuations
coming from different valuation types.
Well, the problem is
nobody understands this
outside of banking.
I tried to make charts like this
several time in a consulting context
and I've yet to meet a
client that can understand
and read this type of chart.
So my takeaway here is that
there are some differences
in consulting compared
to banking presentations,
though I would argue if you wanna learn
the presentation style that
will make you successful
in C level environments,
in broad room environments
of large corporate firms,
then I'd argue that the consulting style
probably will be a bit
more successful for you.
This is at least from my experience,
what works much better
if you wanna communicate
your insights to your leadership
in most business situations
and environments.
So hope you found this helpful
and I wanna say a big
thank you to everybody
who volunteered to send me
their presentations here
for review in this video.
This of course is much appreciated
and I hope that there were some learnings
for many of you out there,
but of course I also want to be clear
that there is no such thing
as the law of slide presentations, right?
So after all, everything
that I said to you
is from my personal opinion.
Of course if you ask other people,
they might have a different opinion.
And of course, if you see
something differently,
very happy to discuss this with you.
Just leave me a comment
below in the comment section.
Very happy to interact here with you
and also to learn from
you from your perspective
and your experiences.
Now, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date
on all the content.
If you want to see even more from me,
follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
I also have a mailing list.
You can sign up via the link
in the video description.
Thanks again to Skillshare
for being the sponsor of this video.
There is a link to Skillshare
in the video description.
I can only encourage you to
make use of the free trial
that is provided there.
In addition to that, as always, of course
a big thank you to all the
members of Firm Learning as well.
You are the OGs.
You're really supporting here
the course on Firm Learning
so thank you so much.
My name is Heinrich, I'm
releasing videos every single week
on Saturday here on my
channel, Firm Learning.
So looking forward to
see you again next week.
Until then, good weekend to all of you.
Keep learning, cheers. Heinrich here.